hello everyone
and welcome to this session on
sql
i welcome everyone
and
today in this session we are going to
talk about
different concepts the basic concepts of
what is in sql
and we will talk about
how do we create tables two dimensional
tables
we will take our sample database as
mysql as an example and i'll show you
how you can write queries
and then we will discuss about different
type of sql commands
sql command structure
we'll show you certain examples
and with that you will be able to
visualize that how sql helps you
in writing in analyzing data which is
the most important thing as of today
so we will be writing certain basic sql
queries and functions
then we will get into different
modularities of sql writing
uh complexities like uh i'll explain you
how to use group by having
very similar to like we make pivots
uh in
excel
uh which we use day to day but it's very
important to understand and correlate
that the way we use and draw pivots
how can we do that in sql and get the
desired results
and then
joins and sub queries that is also when
very essential part of your analytical
skill set which you might be using
subconsciously in your day to day life
as you must be using vlookups in excel
or you must be
joining two worksheets but we will be
doing this live
uh with certain examples the example
data which we will create
uh
for our
session today and so during the end of
the session we will cover how you can
write joins and how you can join two
tables
so with this background uh i'll move
ahead and
talk about what we're gonna
cover
now what are the widely used databases
let me just
quickly
okay
so
let me just
just give me a second
okay
so what are the widely used databases
you have mysql oracle database mongodb
sql server cassandra
and others like hive latin pig
just why is not changing
okay
so uh
okay so what are the widely used
databases right
okay so these are the certain widely
used databases like mysql oracle mongodb
seek microsoft sql server cassandra
and then you have big data databases
like
uh hive impala etc
now
mysql oracle microsoft sql server they
are the most
old uh legacy based databases they are
they are there in the market uh for
pretty long
and they are generally two dimensional
databases where you create tables
like like a typical people who are not
from sql background or does not
understand the keywords like table i
would just try to explain them like a
table is nothing but like your excel
worksheet
uh which you use in your day to day
activity and you have like your excel
headers you create headers and then you
start collating data in excel so the
header columns the headers are nothing
but
called columns in a database table
so typically in in a two-dimensional
database you start creating
excel sheets kind of tables
where you have to start inserting the
data where you start inserting the data
so all these mysql oracle microsoft sql
server they are based on that particular
concept
now there is a second generation of
databases second gen which which have
been prepared with the new
uh advancements where there was a need
due to the new technology advancement
that you wanted to persist
uh
documents json uh
javascript uh based json objects uh
structured objects or you want to
persist some other documentation like
xml json these are the typical data
structures which are now being used
widely so mongodb cassandra
is basically that generation of
databases where you can directly persist
certain documents and you know you can
query on top of that so these databases
are called nosql databases mongodb and
cassandra the the it means not only
sequel
it means that you don't only create or
persist two-dimensional data but you can
also persist
a document which is in json xml or any
kind of format and then you can leverage
the query language structured query
language sql which is
compatible with their platform and use
that to query that particular document
so that is like you know the more
advanced level uh and then you have big
data databases
which can which can
carry huge amount of data create
replicated information for backup
recovery
and for fast retrieval of information so
now in this era where we are living we
have in information getting generated
every millisecond you have huge
applications like twitter facebook
you have information getting generated
from iot devices internet of things
per millisecond so now
the big data
databases are
meant for capturing such an information
which is huge in volume
terabytes and petabytes and then these
databases are at the up to that level
which allow you to easily efficiently
and again
you
have to use again a structured query
language only an sql only in order to
retrieve that information
so ultimately whatever the database
underlying database it is whatever
technology whatever platform you use
whatever
vendor
uh
product you're using either using mysql
you're using oracle microsoft but your
conceptually you need to understand or
you need to learn how to write a
structured query language and that is
what here we are for
okay
now
what is sql
structured query language sql is the
language to communicate with the
database very plain simple
uh
so basically even in uh excel you can
write certain queries power query
uh there is a
an example there are mechanisms today so
each and every tool either it's a
database or a standalone tool will give
you a mechanism in order to
write queries and retrieve information
so query writing
is into multiple segments we will
discuss that in our subsequent slide and
then we will move on to some
live examples uh when i'll share
the example on how to create your
database and query it but sql commands
are very important
now lot of
people aspire to move into data
analytics or probably they are using
data analytics in their day-to-day job
but they are not syntactically aware
or they do not have that skill set to
syntactically
query a database
so then you know this
session which will help you understand
or basically give you a perspective on
how you can create a
query
okay so sql commands help you store
so you so sql is not only for retrieving
information you can also persist you
also persist the information
save the information using sql commands
so you store you process
you analyze and
you can manipulate the databases you can
basically
change the underlying
architecture you can change the
underlying tables so for example
uh
you were expecting you created a column
in which you were expecting that only
numbers
will be inserted so when you created a
table you defined that okay you know the
expected value in this particular column
is always number so you defined a data
type of number to assign a data type of
number to that column but later down the
line
you realize that okay it can that column
can
accept alphanumeric write integers or
strings or string integers like abc123
or one two three
d e f some kind these kind of values can
come so then you can go and change the
data type of your column in the back end
right
and so like in excel when you do a right
click on a particular column and you
change the format so like
like similarly you can go in database
and change the data type of that
particular column and
but that is something which you need to
be aware of while designing your
database right
okay
so that is the whole
objective
before anyone who wants to persist
information in a database
that is his responsibility that he
understand what kind of data he is gonna
receive and persist whether it is uh you
know uh numeric whether it is decimal
whether it is a
string variables uh or or whatever kind
of information you are you are getting
you are expecting then
in a similar fashion you need to create
your database
okay so
so that is the objective so now let's uh
proceed further
okay
so now now
this is just a sample
table uh which we are trying to show you
over here
this is a table called players
you have four columns
now here which is player id
name of the player the country which
he or she belongs to and
the number of goals that player has
done okay so now
if you see it's a very simple
two-dimensional structure data you have
columns and perk and each column you
have data which signify one row okay so
now if you see player id one zero one
then with name sam country usa and goal
six this is one row in database language
we even call it as a tuple okay so this
is nothing but one data
set one row of data which you have
inserted
in this particular table
now if you observe
player id and goals these two columns
are
number columns
and name and country are string columns
so that is the way you would have
when you would have created your table
it would be mandatory for you that you
decide what data types or data type
or what kind of
information is going to go and sit in
the respective column so that you have
to define
initially itself
okay so so we will take a look at that
i will try to create a table uh for you
and we will see how and we will insert
uh information in that
so so just to further analyze you have
six players data
so you can now suppose if there is a
analytic analysis to be performed on
this table there could be so many other
so many different kind of analysis which
can be performed
one question one an analytics can be how
many total goals have been uh you know
uh
done by or
across all the players so exactly what
you will do you will perform a sum of
all the goals which will be 13 23 29
34 37 so 37 goals have been done across
right so now if i have to write a query
in order to get that particular answer
that is what we will try to see in our
session right so how
syntactically you can get that number of
37.
second query can be that
per country how many goals have been you
know done
so here we have all six countries are
unique so all you will get the same
answer what you are seeing over here but
if suppose there is a country which
would have been repeated then that
number of goals would have got to have
grouped by good
would have got added
so we will see we will support all these
statements within example
okay
okay now moving ahead to understand
four basic
different type of sql commands
which you can perform
now as i said
you can insert information
you can
select the information
and then you can do certain other
operation apart from insert and select
so we will see that uh difference uh in
this particular
uh
slide so there are four kinds of
different sql commands one is ddl
which is data definition language
this command the set of commands which
fall under the category allows
you to
manipulate or play you know
change the tables
you can create a table
you can alter the table so the example
which i was mentioning over earlier that
you decided that whether a column you
have to move a column from number to
string then you can go and alter the
table so alter is means modifying the
table drop
you can easily if you have accidentally
by mistake or you don't you have created
a redundant table then you can go and
easily drop that particular table or you
can info truncate the data and one go
you can delete all the rows in the table
so all these kind of manipulation of
data or playing around with the tables
comes under the data definition language
all the syntax all the commands come
under this particular
category
then the next category is the most
important one which is data manipulation
language dml
under this category all your updates
inserts delete commands
all your select queries analytical group
by joins
inner joins whatever we're going to talk
about primarily will fall under the dml
where like the example select
all the players from your table or get
the sum of all the goals
across all the players all those kind of
queries which you will be writing will
come under dml category
now the third is data control language
which generally every database has in
order to provide permissions
what
or what kind of permissions what kind of
activities a database user can perform
on the database so there are grants
which a database administrator can
perform and provide different security
levels to each and every different kind
of user of the database so there
generally you have one database
administrator and you have multiple
database users who can perform select
insert update but generally the database
administrator has the highest level of
access to maintain the database to
maintain the parameters of the database
to monitor the health of the database to
tweak
uh the you know
the processing power or to monitor the
memory the database is consuming all
those kind of activities generally are
done by dba so you don't want to give
that level of access to everyone because
it could lead to
accidentally
you know corrupting the database so you
generally only provide limited access to
the new users which you onboard so you
can grant
different levels of access or you can
revoke okay
the third one the fourth one the
transaction control language is
something which allows you to commit the
information so each and every uh
database comes with a two phase commit
two phase commit one is that after you
have inserted the database
you need to commit the data information
you need to uh basically
tell the database yes you commit this
information which cannot be deleted
means which which if not
provided deleted command will not get
deleted so that is called two phase
commit
generally
you have a provision to do an auto
commit so if you provide that provision
then every information which you are
persisting inserting or updating will
auto get automatically get committed in
your database
and then you also have the provision to
roll back if you have inserted
accidentally or
if you do not want an information which
has to be which has to be committed you
can roll back
now these transaction control languages
the commands can also are very helpful
when you are interfacing with your
database from your programming languages
like java javascript
uh
or dotnet generally you use interface
with your database so you you you create
in your in your programming language
before you start a particular database
session you generally say auto commit
off and when you have done all the
business logic
relevant in your programming language
you do it commit after you have
processed
run your entire business logic okay so
generally when you are doing programming
you are writing your jdbc code there
these kind of features are very helpful
okay
okay i'll just take up
some queries which are i'm seeing on the
portal
what is the difference uh between uh sql
and nosql so sql so basically sql is
structured query language as i told
generally it is more
uh
it's meant for two-dimensional data and
no sql means actually it doesn't
literally mean no sql it means not only
sql so it is an additional feature on
top of sql which allows you to
query
structure different kind of documents
like xml json which are structured data
sets but lying in a one single column or
one single cell in your database so you
can go
navigate to that particular
nodes of a json or an xml and fetch the
information which is not possible in a
typical sql oriented database
okay so now if you see
this is a typical select query structure
you select the name of the columns
column one column two okay
whatever columns you want in your result
set
and then you
start applying filters like in excel
when you select your columns you
generally apply certain filters on the
columns so where clause
in in your select query is like a filter
okay like for example uh if we go back
to our example in the previous slide
you know if i want to say i only want
to i only want information
of
country usa so you will go and apply
filter on
uh country usa okay so that is something
that is like
uh
applying filter which is equivalent to
where clause in
your sql okay so you go
so again if you say okay i want uh to
apply filter on only two players like
player 101 and one zero two so in your
where clause you will only select
those players which are having player id
one zero one and one zero two so so
select query
where you are able to
manipulate your information
so you have a where condition
then you have group by
what is group by group by is nothing but
pivoting
the now the columns on which you want to
pivot it's called as
is called as group by okay so for
example
in my example when i was talking about
the player you want goals per country
so you your group by will be by the name
of the country country column and the
sum of the
goals so your group by columns generally
are non-numeric most so in the group i
you can only use non-numeric columns
like country you can use by
uh your player name etc or if you want
to use numeric player id then they
should those should be the columns which
are meant for
analysis player id so you would not like
to do a sum on a player id at any point
of time right you will always do a sum
on the goals so you can group by player
id you can group by call uh
the country name or the player name but
you will not do a group by all goals
that number the number of goals is
generally
used for analysis some average number of
goals
you want to find what is the maximum
goals done all those kind of
manipulation can be done only on the
goals column
now having column
having column is nothing but
when you are saying after you have done
a group by you want to filter
information after doing a group by
if you want to do the filter
of data filtering of data before group
by you use where clause but if you want
to do the filtering of data after group
by you use having clause
uh so basically you say that okay
if any x any number of cont any country
which has
have goals more than five then you would
have done a group by country
sum of goals and then you have to say
having
sum of goals greater than five so we
will see that
and order by is just primarily for
uh
primarily for sorting ascending or
descending
okay so now with this uh information
let's uh
let's uh go into our database
just let me try to share
okay
okay
i hope
my
workbench is now visible
okay now
i'm gonna show you some live examples of
uh
my data so what we're going to do is
first i'll try to
i've already created a sample database
but i'll try to create another database
for everyone's convenience
so i'm gonna create a database called
sql live tutorial let me call it
tutorial1
so now i'm using mysql as my sample
database platform
over here for everyone to understand so
we're gonna use sql live tutorial
you create the database
and i'll just make it as my default
now
i'll open a sequel editor
sql editor which will communicate with
my database
now let me check how many tables are
there in my database i right now it's
all blank there is no tables in my
database so what i'll do is i'll create
a table
now what i'm going to do is i'm going to
take a dip create a
department table
now please understand over here what we
are trying to do we are trying to create
a department table
with three columns one is
department id which is a numeric field
integer field
then the second is department name which
is a string character field
and i am giving defining the length that
okay not more than 30 characters i am
expecting in this particular column
and location
i am not expecting more than 40
characters
by doing this i am defining the size of
my data set which i can persist in my
department table and also i'm defining
the space
which my database is going to occupy on
the hard disk okay so you will you're
basically defining
what
okay what are the data
types and the columns which you are
going to create
second table which i'm going to create
now is my
employee table
so i am creating a department table and
the employees who belong to which
particular department so i'm generally
creating certain set of columns for
employee like the employee number code
or whatever you want to call it naming
convention the name of first name of the
employee second name of the employee the
job
uh
description what is his designation the
manager
who is his manager what was his higher
date now this is a new data type date
field which is very commonly used you
generally want to capture the time
stamps the dates and it is a very common
thing
salary
and commission basically the float the
decimal numbers
you are expecting salary to be in
decimal so you will define float data
type and
now
the this this column is the id
department id to which the employee
belongs okay
now generally when you're designing a
database
you would want that this
column
i'll
the column which i'm trying to put in
the employee table
should be similar to the column which i
have created in the department table and
even the values in the employee
department column should be same
so for that
there is something called as referential
integrity
though we will cover that in our
advanced sessions but for now
conceptually please understand that
there is a concept called primary key in
the foreign key so we will basically you
need to create a foreign key
you will say
that whatever
department id value will come in the
employee table should be always
existing should be existing in the
department table first
okay so i'll create my employee table
and then now you can refresh
and check there are two tables which
have got created
and now again if you
say
show tables
command
you will see that two tables are now in
your database
okay
so whatever create commands which we
have done these are all ddl commands
data definition
we have not
performed any dml query right now we
have just done some ddl
transactions some ddl commands we have
executed
now
let me
try to insert
some information
by some sample data so what i am doing
is
i am saying insert into department table
values
now
one first is department id
second is department name and third is
the location
uh of the department and i am gonna
insert the data
so five records got inserted
in the table
department
now if you want to cross check whether
okay you know the information got
persisted
you have to say select star
from
department and
run the query and you will get the
desired result you got
five rows
so typical two-dimensional data
columns and rows
okay
next
now as we have populated the department
let's populate
the data in employee table
now i've already created certain sample
data
and
if you see the
values are as per the column sequencing
employee code first name
last name the job manager id
hire date
and salary commission and department id
so i've already taken care that the
department belongs to the department
table
so 17 records have got inserted and i'll
just confirm
whether my data is there
17 rows returned so all my information
got persisted
okay
now
if suppose
as
i was showing in the presentation you
only want selective columns you say
i only want employee first name
comma
employee last name
nothing else in my output
so you can do selective query selective
column selection
okay
so syntactically star
means that you only want you only you
want all the columns
or if you want
selective columns
okay
now
there's another command which allows you
to check
what are the details of my employee
table so if i am using a utility called
sql workbench so that also gives me
these uh
features i can go on employee and i can
check alter table command and check the
details
whatever the description of my table is
or you can check
what is the description by the command
by using this command what is the
description
what are the data types of my columns
whether the null is allowed
any primary key any key column or not
other than that and if you have defined
what could what would be the default
value
of any column then all that will also
come over here so either you can write
describe column or you can say alter
table and you can check the details over
here
okay
now the next one is
that the next example
is
you want to alter the table okay
now
in the employee table
as i was mentioning
there is no primary key primary key
means that
this their val the column cannot have
duplicate values
because first of all the column cannot
have null values
and every value should be unique so if
you want you
you need to define generally in every
table there should be a primary key
which should uniquely identify each and
every row so that there is no data
duplicacy okay
so now
i want to
make my employee code column as a
primary key so what i'll say is alter
table
employee
and
add
primary key
and i'll give the name of my column
emp code
and i'll run this
okay now in order to verify you can go
check
if you now go and check your table
these two check boxes are ticked now
this is what my sequel workbench has
you know read from the table or even you
can say now
describe employee
and now if you see
it is a primary key column
and
null is not allowed okay
so this is how
you play around this is again a ddl
command alter table
you play around with the table you go
you can make changes you can
uh
make changes in the table
and you can validate okay
i'll take a pause and check if anyone
has any questions
so far
okay okay fine
uh okay now
moving on before you know
now i want
my
i want to get
the count
of employees in my employee table if you
remember we had inserted 17 rows so
ideally we should get 17 okay got it we
have 17 records 17 count of 17 in the
employee table okay so this is now this
is what we are trying to solve we are we
are moving into getting into the
analytics part where we are trying to
play around with the table and
uh you know fetch some numbers analytics
so i want the count of employee this is
one example
or
you can also check
you can say emp
code as
total employee count total amp count
from employee
again 17. so either you can select a
column
or you can say select star
now if there would have been duplicate
employee codes now which is not possible
now because we have created a primary
key but if there would have been
duplicate then it would have considered
the duplicate rows also
as a
number but if you want to remove
duplicate you say distinct
so distinct will remove the duplicates
and then give you the count so in our
case
uh every
this is a unique employee okay
so for example
i want
okay like my job is repeating there are
different managers salesmen
if i want distinct
job
okay so now you see there are these
seven
these are the seven distinct jobs which
my employees in my employee table are
performing and if i want the count of
this
this is seven so out of the 17 employees
only seven are performing distinct jobs
okay there are seven distinct jobs which
these 17 employees are performing so
this is one analysis which is available
to you okay
next is
if i want sum of total salary which the
employees are withdrawing
so this is 51 930 dollars
of
salary which uh the total salary which
is being paid out to the employees so
now what you have learned over here is
you have learned this analytical
function called sum
and before that we were using count if
you recall all these functions are also
available in your pivot sum count max
median average so similar to that
pivoting we are doing pivoting using
select queries
now if i want to know the average salary
not the sum
then the average salary which is being
paid out is thousand five hundred
dollars for three three thousand fifty
four dollars is the average salary being
paid across all these 17 employees that
is the goal
then next
calculation
max salary who is receiving the max
salary okay 7 000 is the max salary is
being paid okay
and
even okay so this is the maximum salary
which is being paid then you have
you have another function which is
called as
round this is mathematical utility you
want to round it
your numbers
let me give this with an example of
average salary so if i remove this round
function
i was getting my average salary as
three zero five four dot seven zero five
weighted
to you know uh n number of decimals
but i want to reduce it to two round it
up to two so you can use the
round function okay
so you have
some functions which allow you to
analyze the data and
like count max average
uh sum but these round function is the
mathematical utility function which
allows you to
create mathematically create the value
sanitize the value
okay
now whatever we are doing this we were
playing around with the number fields
you can also manipulate your
string fields right like suppose you
want to
concatenate
employee first name and last name
and
prepare a full name column okay
so see this
you have
a separate column was first name
separate column as last name and then
you have a concatenated column first
name last name and the full name okay
so now there are
numeric utility columns then you have
string utility columns like
concatenation that is one other example
then
you can
also have
you can play around
or you can apply logic like for example
you want the first three characters of
each employee's first name
okay substring which we generally
uh is an algorithm which we would have
used in a lot of other programming
languages or would have used in day to
day
activity
or
similar to this
you want the first three characters you
can use the left function the left
first three characters you can use left
function right
similar same output it will give but you
can also achieve there using a different
utility function
left or
right three left most three or the
right most three
see this
then
you have
another
function called replace
where you want to replace the last name
value some string value variables start
with adam so this in this example only
this the first employee name would have
changed rest all others are same
okay
you want to replace a particular value
with the other one so you can use a
replace function
okay
now moving on
this is
lower case
so you have
basically
another
function for string manipulation
converting all your
values into lower case so you have the
function called lower
okay
now let's take example of
where clause now till now uh till this
moment i was playing around with entire
data set all 17 employees were in my
scope of query but now i want to reduce
my scope of data
to
certain set of
employees
so now what i'll do is i'll apply
a where clause
before performing any other
function on my query i will say only
give me those employees who
job is analyst okay and now i will
perform my sum of salary so now if i
want this query is returning me the
total salary which the
employees are withdrawing with job
category as analyst so this is
one analytical example one query example
second
example for where query is
i want
the list of employees
whose salary is greater than 4000
okay only three
out of 17
are the employees who are having salary
greater than four thousand so now this
where clause so see the importance all
the mathematical
filters like greater than equal to less
than you can perform
uh okay so on on and on
number functions okay on string
functions you can perform equal to
like like for example
i want all my
job
like
starting with
so if you see this
okay so now what i have done is i'm i've
done a function like any
employee
whose job category has a and a coming in
their job anywhere a and a
within their uh string that will come so
manager and analyst have come as an
output so this is like like job like now
if i say if i remove this percentage it
means starting with a a so only analyst
will remain
okay or if i say
jobs which are ending with yst so
analyst again so this is where you can
manipulate the
string variables you can apply filter on
string
another example is this
job analyst but salary is less than
3500
okay so now you have a where clause with
and condition so both the conditions
uh should be satisfied then only you
will get an output so only these two
employees are satisfying this particular
condition
okay
now let's try to apply a filter on our
date column
so anyone who has been hired before 1982
please give me the list
of those
employees
okay
so these are the employees whose higher
date is less than 82 and how i have
achieved that i just use the year
function inbuilt utility
as higher date is a date column the
utility derived the year and then i'm
able to compare it with this value of
1982
similarly i can compare the entire date
select start from employee whose higher
date is less than first jan 1982 so i
can even go to that level of giving the
exact date
or
i want great
higher than greater than 82 but less
than 1993 people who are hired between
82 and 93
okay
so only two employees who have been
hired within that particular range of
date
or
there is another date
utility
function called between okay so which
means that you want people
who have been hired from 1st jan between
1st jan 1983 and 31st december 1992
okay
and it's inclusive of these two dates so
you just
always remember when you're using
between clause it is as good as you are
it's a shortcut for less than equal to
any greater than equal to of those two
dates so it basically simplifies your
sql syntax
then
there was an employee for which my dip i
kept department id as null
so i want they could be possible that
you want to use you want to query data
which has null values so
you cannot use this syntax where
department id is equal to null you need
to say where department id is null
so the database generally
behaves very differently when you are
dealing with null values so you need to
be very careful
how you are writing your queries for the
null values
okay
now let's take an example of our sorting
so i want the employees to be listed
where i am ordering them by
salary highest to lowest okay so the
maximum salary as we had queried earlier
is 7000 so that should come on top and
the minimum salary is 500 that is at the
bottom so my all the employees are in
the
descending order and if you want the
reverse way you put it ascending and the
lowest will come at the top highest will
go at the bottom
okay
then
now
let's take another dml now now so we
have talked about
select queries
where clauses
order by
now let's try to update some information
update my data
okay now i want to change the job
description from analyst to a different
keyword where i'm just trying to
misspell it and
okay
now let me check
okay so the updates have not happened
it's because i first need to run this
command to allow
my
updates to happen
see this all
the job category of analyst has changed
to analyst one okay so i've just renamed
it
just to show you how an update works but
now i'll roll it back i'll make my
update command correct so that further
queries do not get impacted
and it's back to analyst okay
now
let's
look at certain examples of group by
now i'm gonna take another table called
create another table called employee one
and
create it
okay
and in this
i am gonna insert
some new data i'll show you guys
uh
okay so i have created a new table
okay with the
employee id employee name a gender
date of joining department city and
salary now i'll try to apply show you
some examples of group by so now i want
per department total salary being paid
okay in this example so what i'm gonna
show you is
select star from employees now my
question is
per department so when i say per
department you say group by department
then whatever column is in the group by
only that can be used in the select
rest any other column you want to use
you can use only with these
analytical functions like sum
so if you say salary per department
now
this is my answer for department i'm
paying this much salary
and if you notice so if you have to
derive this you have to group by
department okay if you want to see how
much average salary per department you
are paying
you just need to change the function
from some to average
the max salary you are paying per
department you just need to change so in
sales department the the maximum salary
which has been given to any of the
employees is one lakh fifteen thousand
marketing sixty seven thousand
product seventy six thousand so this is
your answer right so you can perform any
kind of analytical function okay
now
i want
let's go back to my select star
employees
okay so in my employees i want per city
per city how many
employees i have right per city so now
i'm asking you per city you say city
then in the select only you can use city
and you say count
of my
employee id okay
emp
id
so i get the answer that in how many in
each city
how many employees i have employed
chicago for
seattle now if you see this information
this is not sorted i want the maximum
number of employees per city so you can
just say order buy
count
descending
and now the information isn't sorted
you have chicago has the maximum detroit
has the detroit and austin have minimum
two and this is a
sorted list of city-wise count of my
employees
okay
now let's go back to this data
now i want how many employees joined in
2005 per
year
of my
joining in x year how many have joined
okay
so what i'll do is
i'll say group by
year of
date of joining
count of employees
order by this rest remain same
okay so if you see
uh in 2009
the maximum number of employees joined
then in 2011
uh till 200 in 2005 you can also order
by actually year of
joining descending
like this or ascending
this will make sense okay so from 99
2000 1999 till 2019 how many employees
joined per year in my form
so this is that particular example
okay
now
moving one step further we want to use
having clause okay
so now i want to do filter after
performing my group by so what i'm
trying to do is
i have identified what is the average
salary in my each department and
i want those departments where average
salary is less than 80 000 okay
so only
if i don't have this having clause i
have
one two three four five six seven seven
departments but out of these seven
departments
only
five have
average salary less than 80 000 so this
is a filter after you have performed a
group by so this is one very very
important example
which i wanted to show you
so where clause is before you apply
group by and
having clause is after you have applied
group by okay
similarly
when we did a group by city we can
perform this
calculation only those cities which have
count employee count of equal to three
only give me those so this is that
particular list
okay
where count is equal to 3
having so after
applying having i am after applying
group by i am further filtering the data
okay
now coming to the other very important
aspect is coming back to my old table of
employee and department i want to now
make a join between
my employee and department table let's
forget about the employee one table
now
i have a common column between employee
and department table is the department
id okay
so what i'll do is i'll say
select
star
from employee
e
comma
department
d
where
e dot d p t underscore id equal to
d dot dpt underscore id
so i'll say give me the e dot star
comma
d dot star
columns from both the tables
only when
my data is matching
so only
those records will come
for employees who are having a
corresponding department id in the
employee table
okay none other than that so if i take a
count
of the rows
it's 16
but originally i had 17 because there is
one employee whose department id is null
so that employee will not come in this
result set
this particular employee code
is not part of this result set
nine triple seven so if you see
nine triple seven
is not here
okay which because the the null value
cannot be joined with any other column
so that particular row has been ignored
so that's this is the meaning of join it
means look up all the department ids
from the employee table
and then look up in the department table
whichever matches please bring that as
an output that is the so this is an
example of
inner join this is what we call as
inner join
now i'll also give you a example of
sub query
so if i say
give me the employee name
and salary
from the table okay
which is
the top four
the top four
salaries
okay so these are the four employees
which have the top four and amongst them
the highest
this is the highest okay so what i've
done is i have written a sub query which
says give me the top four employees who
have the highest salary and out of those
top four i am picking the one
which has the which is having the
highest salary among the four
so this is an example of
sub query
so you first write an inner query give
it an alias and then on top of it you
write another query
okay so now
i'll take certain q a's
anyone has any questions we can take
that up
so
okay so uh
limit means that out of the
number of records i only want to limit
it to number of so like for example i
have
select star from employees order by
salary descending okay this we have
already seen so i have
ordered my
employees by salary from highest to
lowest and out of that i only want the
four
four records the top four records of
this so i'll say four limit to four okay
so when i say
the sub query so sub query is nothing
but an independent query so first you
say order by salary descending
then you take the top
four employees now out of these four
employees this is now my independent
result set
out on this result set now
i am again
writing a query on top of it select
employee name and salary only from this
result set
and then again order by salary
descending or even ascending and you
will get the lowest one then you can
play around with it
this is the one
among these four jack is the one who has
the lowest salary and if you make it
descending
joseph is the one who has the highest
salary among these four okay so limit
means limiting your result set to a
particular number of record count
so there are limitless possibilities
there is no limitation
as you advance into sql world
you there are so many possibilities so
many problem statement but this is just
a stepping stone into the particular
direction so it will help you
learn further and advance
into more analytical functions
yeah we can write multiple sub queries
there is no limitations
you can create
uh one you this is one sub query then
you can another
sub query you can write
but just give a alias as different
and say order by salary
limit 5
that way you can create n number of sub
queries
uh
okay
i
hope everyone had a great learning
session and uh
will definitely help you guys
in uh further advancements in the
analytical space
and i wish everyone i best of luck
thank you
you